what are your thoughts on Vladimir Putin
and his mindset these days
uh I I don't I don't his mindset I think
when we look at from a foreign policy
perspective I'm not going to pretend to
claim to know what's going through his
mind but I think if we look from the
outsider's view in as you have uh NATO
continuing to expand continuing to
surround uh Russia you look back to what
Putin has said has been his most concern
from the very greatest concern at the
very beginning which was uh not being
surrounded on all sides by NATO armed
countries and feeling that threat so
this this latest development of of
um what looks to be the United States
providing f-16s either directly or
indirectly to Ukraine this is going to
be a very serious escalation uh in this
war that that will lead could lead to
those disastrous consequences nuclear
that we're talking about the reason I
asked is there's a large contingency of
people on the right who actually have
higher approval ratings of Putin than
they do of Biden which is concerning I
get you know if you're American whether
you like buying or like Trump you should
support our president
as a primary focal point rather than a
Russian
dictator yeah why do you think people
are so fast I won't even begin I won't
even begin I have no I have no idea but
but I think it's more important I I
don't think we should blindly support
anybody
period I think it's more important for
us as Americans regardless of political
party to stand together on our ideals
and principles uh that that we celebrate
and that we should cherish in this
country those principles of freedom and
our god-given rights that are enshrined
in the Constitution those are things
that
um they are under attack they are under
threat and they are things unfortunately
that we cannot take for granted at this
time when people are saying well hey
maybe the First Amendment uh you know no
longer applies that it's okay to silence
and censor uh and cancel uh certain
people's uh Speech these are things that
that we used to all be able to agree on
and and even something as sacred as the
first amendment is is no longer sacred
unfortunately and
um it should concern everyone I'll give
you my response okay I respect anybody
that loves their family defends their
Heritage defends their denomination
whatever Faith they have
and fights for their country to protect
their people and not giving deals to
people on the outside that they're for
sale
I don't have to like you uh but I can
respect you in the industry business
you've been I've been competing for a
long time guys sold out their people all
the time they would sell their agents to
get money on the side and nobody knew
about they would sell their employees
they would sell everything they could in
a way of running their agency they got
you know 5 000 agents hey I'll give you
a million dollars if you also sell this
nobody knew about it we never sold out
uh he has protected his country as a
nationalist of Russia
that's something you gotta respect
unfortunately in America you know my
sister sent me the national anthem for
Germany okay I want to read this to you
this is Germany's national anthem okay I
don't know if you just send it to me
this was a few days ago it says Germany
Germany above everyone above everyone in
the world guess what uh Deutschland
Deutschland
okay you know somebody must say that's
Hitler I totally get it but in America
we're embarrassed to read our pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America or you know our
prayers that we have these things that
we did were embarrassed the fact that
America was number one for so long and I
respect anybody that is proud of whoever
they are by the way I don't have to
agree with your political philosophies
but I respect the fact that you uh
respect where you come from that's a
whole different conversation I don't
want to get into that part that's just
my thoughts on uh Russia and FYI no we
shouldn't be supportive of that guy
America First is what it needs to be and
this criticism that Americans are
apologizing about being America First is
the most pathetic thing ever can you
imagine you having to apologize for
being married to your wife and every day
I have to apologize for your kids you
have to apologize for your parents you
have to apologize what do you mean I
have to apologize I'm an Assyrian I'm
our man I'm proud I'm from Iran I'm
proud that I was born and raised in Iran
I'm proud to be an American I'm proud to
be a veteran I'm proud I'm proud We
ought to be proud some people are not
proud of being Americans and that's
pathetic in my eyes so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
foreign